[Music]
ah
you know what she did for me my girl and
you might cut this out but you know what
she did for me my girl this is the day
that i was like okay when i when i make
some money i'm proposing to you when i
make more money we get married
it didn't happen because i did pay for
the wedding but
welcome back to the true geordie podcast
christmas special rory have you ever
sent a dick pic no i have no one to send
it to you why do you send your mrs big
pics i'm pretty good with my cat dude
like her i [__] love her
have any of you's ever been
propositioned by a man yes tell it come
on i wanna i need to know this so i went
to milan fashion week you were asking
you're already trouble yeah you've been
asking for it wait so they wanted this
to happen rory i just need to fill you
in there's an old viral video of a horse
[__] a man of the art a man
not a boy
if you could only [__] the dream woman
but you had a double team i was your
mate if i saw an erect penis that wasn't
my own in real life i'd rant
i'm not reading my dating profile i know
you should because i think you'd be
insensitive ultimately i'm a romantic
guy and i'm out there i'm trying to find
love on my simple pleasures all right i
said i've said wine okay you want to
look at the chocolate
[Music]
welcome back to the true jordy podcast
christmas special
sponsored by jim sharp big love to them
and also it's also kind of sponsored by
whoever make these cheap santa hats i'd
imagine jim sharp could make those if
they cheated
have you seen the prize mine was well i
mean 5.99 actually isn't cheap but you'd
think they would be can we play and the
girl who is clearly modeling them on the
little price tag there can we get a
she deserves something well she's got
how much do you think rory paid for his
glasses there how many times how much
should he pay for them elton john
they're robbing they're good no what
about rayman did you see ho ho there's
nothing
yeah yeah yeah do you get it yeah
yeah yeah it's like when you look across
the table it's what you see in it but i
love it i love it i love everything
about them they are they are they are
fantastic are we uh did they keep them
in the entire i mean you can't and i'm
not i mean it's like when when spencer
first came on the poker it doesn't hide
your emotions i know i mean i've got
i've got an interchange i've got a sort
of outfit change as if i was cheryl cole
in her pump what you're you're getting a
back tattoo i've got i know i've got an
outfit changed halfway through she
ruined it wasn't a back tattoo it was a
pesh
type of tattoo
i like tattoos
but
do you need to just cover your whole
arse with roses it's a bit weird yeah
there's nothing there's very little
that's my favorite noise in the world
the right nose
that's it the pop the pop of the verve
but no you don't need to whatever
whatever we were talking about just then
there is never a justification to cover
your entire pech
in fake roses are you all right loss
where you going oh it's
what's biggie amazing
um we should dress biggie as a reindeer
well you are that kind of guy aren't you
at christmas
you must wear reindeer outfits i don't
know how well you take the weight he
doesn't even like wearing it
i'll put it on him actually but he's
just in a bit of a funny do whatever you
wanted but don't touch my dog
no no he's just in a funny mood at the
minute i don't know what's happening loz
has been getting us loads of posh
whiskeys today bro i got like four under
the table um you already started on one
i have the japanese one yeah thank you
very much japanese you want some of this
as well uh it's just the champagne
champagne for you well blue champagne is
it but
for you you put ice in your glass any
champagne i'll say one yeah thank you so
much i'll touch it a verve
i'm going for that
winter storm so rory loves christmas
and not only do i love christmas but i
hate people who don't well you'll hear
elliott then because he [__] hates it
don't you really he's from stockholm
that's probably not no they don't have
to come and talk come on come on you
won't be able to see him though he's
singing the world
try and avoid putting the tree up for as
long as possible and then as soon as it
goes up 12 p.m christmas night into
boxing day why is that hateful seriously
everything's wrong
i thought of you as soon as he said that
i hate that attitude really no but
just hate that attitude just embrace it
it's so good everything about it's so
good it brings out the best in people
everyone's in a good mood
drinks to be drunk songs to be sung for
a period of time i did think jimmy
savile was the one who sung um are you
hanging uh
[Music]
my mum for years didn't know about the
mba and when i was a kid i thought that
michael jordan had aids because
magic john magic johnson
and mum went of course he's one of the
aides in the and i went i don't think he
is
but that's why he became personal
honestly as a kid i was genuinely like
[__] he's doing all this
aids but do you know the the this is a
weird bit of trivia but the music video
you will hear uh loud drumming in the
background like boom boom boom boom boom
now it's actually him just beating he
didn't realize the drummer in that music
video that they were just supposed to
mime and not the track so you could say
hear his drumming so much louder because
he's off his tits on drugs which is
which um um are you oh yeah that one so
at the end you'll hear him banging the
drums so loud because he's off his face
um second best christmas song of all
time second to
second two the pulse shank yeah shane
mcgowan um
yeah the woman who you have just
confirmed her death to the boys
sad death shane mcgowan toothless and
brilliant in equal measure like i rate
that a rape he was equally lacking teeth
how brilliant black teeth brilliant
brilliant brilliant are they not a
one-hit wonder the way you know the pogs
are
they're one hit wonder they're not a one
they're gonna
with the kids all the time sorry
no i do
that's shane mcgowan's is definitely the
best should we start the podcast now
we're just starting from now from now on
from there sorry what are you saying
shane mcgowan is the best christmas song
james magazines is the best christmas
strong of all time undoubtedly oh that's
the best christmas what's the
competition christmas film i'm gonna go
see
home alone there's certain films that i
watch over christmas but they're not
necessarily a festive film so they're
festive for me
are you talking about like die hard and
stuff yes no that would be your
christmas song because apparently
there's a christmas tree in it there it
is and therefore it could be it is a
christmas tree there's always that guy
there's nothing like like it's not it's
not christmas it's not though it's not
christmas in the way that home alone is
christmas
christmas it's got christmas
one two
oh
joe biden sorry they're all theodores
yeah but yeah
i'd say favorite christmas i'll tell you
a film that wrecked me up miracle on
34th street
that's what i think santa looks like
that center yeah
yeah that's what's happening but miracle
on 34th street is there
yeah yeah you've seen a film called
paulie about a parrot oh bruv i watched
that in cinema that is so sick when they
clip his wings they clip this parrot's
wings it makes me if if i could find a
geezer that clipped his wings i set him
on fire
i'm so angry that this parrot and a
parrot chats yeah the parrot's like
please don't clip my wigs and they do it
and then you can't fly and it that is a
heartbreaker you see molly and me
how choked you get during that
[__] hell do you used to work on alan
carr the tv show sometimes you're a bit
like him he's brought it out
today
molly me kills do you know that you know
what's mad about anna carr gay
very sure very on the spectrum of gay
gay
yeah it goes it goes from like the
gayest is alan carr and the straightest
you're going to have to be eddie hearn
eddie from eddie
what's the greatest man in the
no
jesus
you mean that there's never any question
whether eddie hearn nobody's ever gone
jack and eddie heard
he could be in chariot sauna in vauxhall
and nobody would think he was gay now
describe a chariot
yeah exactly well i've heard about i
don't know
it's one of the things that it's like a
marquee event in london well i have no
idea what you're on about boxing's a
weird area at the same time at night
sauna in vauxhall south london where
boovy lives
it's very much a man's area down there
i'm moving out of south florida
do you mean gay men yes yes
there's a sauna there and then there's a
pub literally there's a pub right now
called the voxel tavern right and i used
to run there on a sunday
swallowing
i don't know why it would be called that
but i used to run i used to run past
there on a sunday you can't run another
i'm not kidding this is
there was one time where a gay uh like
this drunk gay man tried to and i it
could have been anyone but he might have
been straight but he was very camp at
the time i will say he
ran with me for a few minutes did you
have a big head with a bristolian accent
so i went to milan fashion week
okay i didn't realize it you were asking
for it
you were asking for it for it uh the way
i was dressed was perfectly respectable
actually
so
uh basically i went to milan fashion
week i didn't realize it was milan
fashion week it was also in ac milan um
juve that's a good cover story yeah
right yeah i really wanted to go
to fashion i mean football i really
wanted to go to the fashion show with
all of the football football yeah okay
so you ditched the football um and uh a
friend of mine that i went with we went
out for the night and we were like oh
it's fashion week we should like kind of
try and latch onto one of these groups
of people and get into one of these
fashion parties so there's like a gucci
party um armani party
and so we approach a group of uh like
just like a big what looks like fashion
people my mate's like yeah we're here
for the weekend we're here for the
football fashionistas fashion easters
yeah now those people if they were to
see me now would probably go
good god like look turn into a
[Laughter]
turned into a
so we get in this we get in this car
with these people we drive to the club
and we get to a gucci bar and there's a
woman who's sort of uh taking us under
her wing if you like because she the
madam she organizes
she was really kind she gave me some
clothes
they're a little bit tight these clothes
are gonna change that's a
so the guy the guy who was a designer
the designer of the group all night
um like kept coming over and being and
like trying to touch me inappropriately
how inappropriate oh to the point where
like he was trying to put his hands down
my trousers [__] that
you know but but
i mean rory what i mean is what i mean
is like in fact in front of everyone
else now there's going to be people in
the comments going oh but laws was
entertaining and whatever yeah i was
definitely not doing that i'm going to
write that in the comments yeah you're
good
dancing on the dance floor it's me and
like it's just this group nanito in the
sopranos yeah it's yeah it's just me
right what was vito what was vito in the
sopranos just dancing like would that be
a thing i don't know
what are you doing i should be able to
dress however i want yeah so what
they're a pair of dungarees mind your
own
eminem wears them
so he came over to me why he had a
chainsaw with him so he came over to me
and he just grabs my face
and he tries to like force kiss me and
i'm not but you know like in those films
where they're two men have got the knife
and they're trying to force it into the
other guy
he's trying to force my face towards him
and i'm trying to force my face away
from him so it's like you know when
they're like this guy this guy is
awesome like
this is like a guy who's capable of go
you got me too bro you know what yeah
that is my mind
mine was a lot more
pleasant let's be honest
because if this happened to you the guy
would have died and you wouldn't be here
yeah you can hit him without it being
homophobic at that point i didn't finish
the story i didn't finish the story i
just um i slipped some viagra in his
drink
pushes past my mate and the girl is like
the madam turns to us and she goes
and we're like [__] like yeah it's
zlatan he's got his hair down and stuff
he's [__] huge like he's like
he's like as wide as you but he's like
as handsome as me yeah
yeah
but like and and he looks and he's got
this shirt on where everyone can sort of
see how chiseled he is you know he
dresses like he's not put his over shirt
on
so he so he pushes by and sort of moves
over and the woman goes that's latin and
we told her we were like we want to meet
zlatan he's not playing in the game this
weekend she was like that could happen
and we were like
so anyway she goes over to him and she
goes imagine you're me right and you're
my mate
and i and she goes
and zlatan just goes
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's not mad it's not a class it's it's
a it's just a it's just flagging the
pack did you have context rory about
your opinion so when i met her she
lived around my neck of the woods north
london
with a little baby that she just had
with her doting father who was also her
husband right
family unity
all of a sudden she's hit about 40
and she's gone
i'm now gonna go and shag a 22 year old
because i got a six-pack and i saw a
photo this is where it gets double mad i
saw a photo
of her
her baby
her ex-husband
and
all in the swimming pool in there in
their swimwear
prof don't let him knee you're fat what
are you doing and they're all friends
and everybody's happy basically she
loves the other guy because he's
probably her rock and you know he's 40
now but she also wants the gays with a
six-pack she's done the double you know
the way to the swinton you know the way
tina swinton has like a man she's
married two geezers and she has a man
that she likes to have sex with but also
like a gazelle that she because that's
just the beach but that's a character
you've got a goomba she's got a gum
but the goomer and her wife are friends
carmilla
isn't number four
she's killing it bro no i don't know i
mean in a week yeah
if i did
absolutely good luck to her but i think
she's also gone mad
but no i do think she has gone insane so
i think
i think that she's gone back because
also i feel like i'm a very very wise
huge man and what happens is to
certainly can we put this in with the
name bleep down no no no no please
keep it and keep it keep going what
happens
to certain
goals girls girls in particular who are
very attractive particularly when
they're young so they're very useful
they've had 20 years old jesus loving
them all the geezers loving them all the
geezers
suddenly the geezers 22 they're looking
at you they don't they know they don't
care because you're 40.
they're looking at some twenty they're
looking at 22 year olds yeah 22 year old
who's got what you have yeah but what
but it's all in the right place and all
of that exactly and there's no plastic
surgery no disrespect though because
some four-year-old women are out of this
world but at the same time generally
that is the the rule
of life the wheel of fortune circles
it's the circle of life that's what the
wheel of fortune is the wheel what
happens what happens to men as well
absolutely but what happens is these
girls they don't always so what should
happen is you should get older you
should get a rich child you should move
on but also
just adjust to it like adjust to not
being the person you were you do and
embrace the person you become correct
but what happens is
what happens is they don't all do it so
if they're wise and they're and they're
and they're switched on they just become
a family person and whatever they had a
wicked time when they were young but
some of these girls in order to feel
validated they feel like they have to
keep getting shagged by 22 year old
geezers with six packs
so they do
but they don't want to give up their
family life either i'll tell you who did
it
do you win mel sykes who used to be like
boddington's and all that could you know
she went mad can you uh
and all of a sudden she's putting things
on twitter genuinely about a 22 year old
that she met on twitter she met a fellow
on twitter who was standing there you
know these weird gazers are like six
pack and that yeah she ended
sponsorship i think they've ever had
a shout out to jim's books
to feel obliged to like stand there
nobody wants to see your [__] armpits
mate just put the top on just get back
in the gym spot but equally
she decided she decided now she's 50.
she needs to like keep shagging young
people mm-hmm she's met gives her on
twitter
follow her name do you know what she did
she's 50 years old she's got kids she
put a tweet out whatever his name is
quote currently hanging out the back of
me okay you've gone mad you've gone back
you've gone man
you've got internet phones you have a
problem you've got an internet forum
can i just see what the problem is
i kind of see rory's point because men
are
generally speaking
more likely to want to upgrade to a
younger model as they get older whereas
women i feel like are the better sex in
that sense and are more likely to to be
a unit with their guy just no matter
what through
good
chicks yeah and and shout out all the
women out there who are like that but
the problem is when you're a woman who
wants to do what the men do and want to
[__] the younger guy so let's say you're
40 and you want to [__] a 22 year old
guy the problem is when that 22 year old
giza hits 30
you know you're gonna be 40 [__]
eight loves and then he's 30 looking at
these 22 year old girls himself going
oh i've got to see you later now and i'm
going to use all the things you taught
me on these younger women right and put
it in the practice and knock the [__]
out
roy's right yeah
[Laughter]
she does some weird brand integration
do you know that yeah you know what i'm
saying you're making memes
weird and it's wrong
this is it doesn't make you worry about
your own life a little bit is that why
are you thinking are you thinking if
that was me though is that is that is
that what you what is it that bothers
you about it oh i had my why why are you
bothered yeah you keep bringing this up
rory i'm not bothered
it's because i'm it's because i'm a very
sage older man and i can see it i can
see you know you know these i can see it
when my mates go out with these girls
that are all into the grand botox i can
see i'm just like mate you know what it
is rory you bring us onto an interesting
subject that's been on my brain for a
little while what kind of woman would
you be it's like i've got no problem
with a man or a woman
putting pictures online to themselves
where they're looking kind of good right
good for you you feel good you want to
look good you want to show off a little
bit i'm all about that but when your
whole life becomes focused around how
you look taking these pictures of
yourself looking immaculate using
filters
wearing clothes and then sending them
back you know all of this thing of
posing outside of restaurants you don't
even [__] eat in the whole thing
paying for it at
and this is the thing is people might
look at me and go you're a [__]
hypocrite you happen to be uh
semi-famous or whatever but the point is
is
it's an upshot of what i like to make i
like to make interviews i like to make
videos
ambition of the youth when i was a kid
was the same as the ambition of the
youth today but but the changes then
it's very stark and it's very worrying
this the change is this when i was a kid
everyone wanted to be famous everyone
wanted to be john franco zola dennis
burkham like if you're around my way you
wanted to be yeah
right you wanted to yeah liam gallagher
whatever you wanted to be famous but you
wanted to be famous because you're
wicked at football you wanted to be
famous because you're wicked at boxing
you wanted to be famous because you're
wicked at anything whereas now genuinely
people go i want to be famous and you go
okay wicked
so to be famous you're going to be
amazing at what like nah
i'm just going to go on love island i
just want to be this is the thing right
like one of the most famous people
in our culture right now is a girl
called molly mayer tommy fury's
girlfriend right so many girls are
looking at her and wanting to be like
her and aspire to and most of them are
because she's famous she's rich she
looks like gays with a six-pack
exactly right but the point is like if
you were to say it to me now what is her
career highlight what is she created
that's special what what has she done
that's meaningful she's the creative
director of pretty little things
she said i did it irrespective of love
island didn't she uh and to be fair she
had a bit of a name before no but but
let's kind of no no but you half rate
that as well i remember when we spoke
about it at one point like months ago
you said kind of rate that she's i wrote
herself i rate that she sustained it but
don't you think how does she sustain it
because there's other people that will
come out of that yeah and they won't
have a way to sustain it so then they
just
get me because i agree
anyone like that if you can make it work
for you good on you all i'm saying is i
don't think other people
should be aspiring to be like that oh
yeah yeah yeah she's better than women
um it's a one-off she's the one who went
on the tv show and made a permanent
success of herself she is a fraction
there's more people committed suicide on
that show than there is
exactly right
and the reason people are committing
suicide on it is because it's that quest
for fear
it's an empty one it's an empty one when
you become famous and you realize your
whole life is under the microscope
that's unfortunate [__] it's not unfair
she said she said this is this is a
quote from her
irrespective of love island i would have
made it and that is she had already made
she already had me she has a lot of i'm
not gonna i'm not quite
what is she
it would be like me saying to you you've
made it i would have a hundred and fifty
thousand subs if it wasn't for no no no
no no no that's what he's saying you
know i could go well i would have done
it anyway but bro you were you were good
that's like very good
you've got a platform
she is not the one to be modeling your
life on is all i'm saying and yeah and
the point i'm making is that they're
unicorns in a in a world full of failure
full of misery because
they are they have some talent about
them
the general people who are looking at
them going i wish that was me and
they're getting cert these these chicks
are getting surgery they're
photoshopping the [__] out of their
pictures they're doing anything and
everything i find it pitiful like i
genuinely think it's a terrible
indictment on on british society you're
saying if you were young now i would do
it no no hang on hang on that's very
different that's very different i would
100 conform to it but if i but i pity
myself having to did you go on love
island if you were 20 right now no no
probably not because when i would advise
someone when i was young big brother was
a thing and it was never appealing to me
that's what we lucky though because i
remember big brother become a thing in
year seven and that's like when we were
already deciding what we kind of want to
be and what we want to do in that so
imagine you're in europe for free to at
that point and then you're growing up
into that where big brother's blowing up
all these things you become a dick
we've seen it as well we've been what we
do yeah because we were some of the
first through the door early on uh
obviously you had poetry you guys coming
through ocelot coming through and all
that all the same and then you start to
see we didn't think we could make a
living out of this or at least i didn't
when i started doing it and then i i
happened to oh [__] i made a living out
of it like it was an accident and people
saw us doing it not clocking that maybe
at times we weren't getting paid or
whatever the graft you're putting in
and they just expect to get it straight
away and now you're seeing that era
where managers come in
one rant and i'm making it like
something like that if i do this i'll
make it or if i do that i'll make it the
worst of it the worst i've ever seen i
went on a stag do to ibiza in about
2019. we're in ocean beach club buying
bottles of champagne the keys are buying
a bottle of champagne's an apprentice
plumber do you know like nobody's got
the money for it but everyone's
everyone's doing it they have what they
want my bath up and all that but you
want their moment though don't they yes
but it's pretty tense what you have to
understand but it is pretense but the
celebrity thing
is also slightly pretense that we're
buying into a little bit the lie that
really because you're good at acting
there is somehow status above that i
think it's damaging i think i get it
it's not something to aim towards it's
not a north star but i get i don't know
what you're saying again it's a part to
the public it is when i was in this
ocean beach club at this stag it was an
eye-opener for me it was terrible ugly
it was it was ugly culture it was really
ugly it was
everyone you know like where you look
looking over your shoulder looking at
the water i be through the pictures
wayne lineker's over there gosh he might
retweet us let's go and have a selfie
with him quick he might stick his face
and it became
i was like this is so destructive this
this this
youth what's going on now for youngsters
so it's really so this is what i'm
trying to get to is
those young people and it feels like
it's more of a feminine
movement than than male but men are
doing it too mandem are there too no no
no no doubt
but the point i'm making is 20 years old
to 30 years old is in my opinion the
most pivotal part of your life that is
when you are shaping yourself that's
when you can you're a person yeah and
that's when you can change your life so
there's still time bro you can improve a
few years left i'm so glad i never had
many years on youtube you know
[Music]
and this is i think why partly when you
get older you
i think you appreciate and you realize
quite how fortunate you are
but i had
my kid was born
in 2019
january
chelsea lost to arsenal that day
she was born
mate
everything felt all right at the time
but i didn't really have a job i didn't
really at all i was working at a company
called ball street that had ended
i was then looking for work and in my
head i was always going to be all right
i was always going to tap up lawrence
and get a job at football daily maybe i
was always going to tap up adam boltwood
and get a job at
spencer's
i was always going to find something
because i was all right i was going to
be okay didn't quite happen like that it
didn't fall for me at all
my daughter was born i kind of nicked a
bit of work here and there but nothing
really
and it culminated in it so that was the
january in the
june
our dear friend adam baldwin got married
in ireland
i went to the wedding i couldn't really
afford to go to the wedding my daughter
was wild at the time she had colic which
meant this i hadn't slept six months
literally answered six months
crazy just staying out i was not turtle
stayed up all night watching sunderland
until i died man
craig crazy time went to um
went to adam's wedding and i kind of
pressured my wife to go which was
probably the wrong thing not in a bad
way just in like
firstly this will be fun this will be
great for us we should go it'll be a fun
night we haven't had any time away or
any time at all together so let's go
equally adam's like one of my good
friends man let's go to his wedding it's
important
paid for it victoria my wife then when i
need to get home so we had flights
booked for four o'clock in the afternoon
victoria that morning
six i was so hungover victoria went we
need to go now we need to get i need to
see go see clementine all right let's
i'll book new flights so i paid for new
flights
skinned me
i didn't even realize quite how much i
had no dough i had no work i had nothing
going on at all
when i got to the airport i was dying
where i was hungover i think i was sick
i was like okay i went into like w.h
smith there or whatever to buy some
water
and when i went to the thing i bought a
bottle of evian i've tried to pay it was
no there was no money there was no money
in the account my account
oh my god i literally have no like
literally i'm a i'm a father
with a wife
with no job who lives in a one bedroom
flat my kid is in my bedroom
six stories up in the air like i don't
have like what am i you know when i'm
going on then i'm on linkedin and things
like that
i don't even know what my job is let
alone
what
i don't know what's right here it goes
profession i was like
[__] chancer i don't know like what
do i write
anyway when i tried to pay as i couldn't
afford it
i nicked it i had no choice but i had to
knit what i was so thirsty man i had the
sew first thing i had to knit what so i
nicked it and i had a sort of
existential crisis and like you know
people talk about um
like mental health and that touch wood
i've always been sweet
i haven't had it i haven't i hear
stories and whatever and thank god
despite various
you know
single parent family he grew up on my
nan grew up in a council flat shared a
room with my man despite things that in
theory lead to that i've been well lucky
i haven't i've always felt secure and
whatever but i had what on my scale was
uh
it was like a breakdown but but but not
it was just me going just [__] this is
existential now this is
this is me
can't afford a five euro bottle of water
at an airport robbing bastard robin yeah
no but when you so where where were you
were you sitting down i've seen that do
you know it's funny you can remember
like the minor details i remember was
listening i had a podcast on at the time
and i was sitting there listening to
this story about eddie cavanaugh loving
jamie carragher like
but going
[__]
kid i got a baby like what you do what
is happening
thank god
thanks to you two a lot it spun it spun
six months later four months later
but at that point i remember going oh my
god like what what is happening
and where do i go from here
culminating in me going on linkedin i
don't have a job i don't i don't know i
don't have a job
i don't have a profession you know for
example but imagine it happened to you
if i said right turn the camera's off
brother
so turn the cameras off
what are you who are you like what do
you do
that's the question i had to ask myself
which is a terrible question but it's a
terrible question especially
when i've got my little girl it's three
months old
in a one bed flat
you know when you're like
this is this is bad now that's
terrifying yeah proper proper
and thank god i think i'd say three
months after that
it spun
thank god
you know that point though right that
people get new it's about holding on
through the chaos and going i've just
got to keep here stay with it and look
and like you say it will change but some
people don't get that like you know when
you say you've never had mental health
problems and people go how does suicide
happen when you're already
in a medical depression
and then the [__] hits the fan
that's how those people don't get that
three months extra they go i can't take
i can't take it because also there's
like a very
primitive
i think it depends on the person that
you are i suppose but there's a very
primitive
thing that's expected of
in my opinion and look people go this is
like
me being very primitive or whatever not
modern but in my opinion
gage's responsibility is to provide for
his family
and and look
that isn't how people think now because
everybody's meant to whatever but in my
head
i provide for my family yeah no matter
what i provide for my family and it got
to the point where i was like
i don't know if i can
and then it becomes really problematic
and that's when what happened is i never
felt i never got low i never got
properly low but what i did get
is sort of desperate in as much as like
you start weighing up
okay i need to make some money what's
the answer here what
i've got
i know and then you start exploring
well i know guys i grew up if i know him
i know that he can be
but you know i mean it gets it gets
desperate again and thank god
it's it spun quick enough to not spiral
into like
problem but it was my one insight
into life
that i didn't really understand which is
now positive can i ask you a question do
you think that is symptomatic of the
industry that we're all in because i'm
gonna i'm gonna say honestly obviously
not the same level as you have because
obviously i'm a lot like younger than
you i feel like obviously i know your
narrative and you two as well i've had
that a similar kind of existential
crisis
who am i in the digital media football
youtube space and it's a do you think
some if you were more in tv if this is
if this happened 20 years ago do you
think you'd be a lot more stable do you
think it's just downs the fact you're
trying to find your space in this
emerging kind of world but it's a very
it's and you've now made it through and
you've done really well out of it
john trying to say people have different
triggers though like
i've had certain moments like that which
have never been because of work
like i always think if i need to get a
job in mcdonald's i'll go do it i don't
i'm not too proud to do that do you know
what i mean but be good at that at the
same time
other things can trigger me to
go into the there's been
like i have a problem with death like
death [__] me right up so it's like
you're ones where like you don't know
what you're going to happen next like
mine is just
but you have you always been i've got so
many people in my life where it's like
yeah do you know what it is
sometimes like you're watching do you
ever worry i'm adam i'm a youtuber dude
is that your identity
not because i don't know what i'm saying
yeah exactly that's what i'm trying
to say
adam self-identifies as
something else
compared to what he and that's that
sounds like a same thing for him to do
where do you think you are then boovie
in this space what do you think you are
well i've been in the i've been in the
game for six years seven years i've been
behind camera producing videos i've
known you guys for a long time maybe not
in the same way in terms of being on
camera like you guys have done but
one minute i'm a video producer one
minute i'm a i'm a photographer a sex
guy or an editor or i'm something i'm a
man city influencer i mean it's surreal
and you have to you have to you have to
have an umbrella kind of approach and
just say you're everything
at all times otherwise
you can't be attached to the sweet song
no but i appreciate it
you have to be dynamic otherwise you're
going to miss opportunities you know so
if you said to me oh look tomorrow do
you want to talk about man city
i'll i'll do that i also have
that dynamic no but no or the day after
you want to edit video or day after day
you should do all of that for boovie
yeah you're looking for because you are
who is the movie i didn't quite get you
at the start and i probably told you
straight to facebook
you are sick bro and like i don't think
the people in the audience are finally
coming around to it but and i i'll be
honest when i first met you i don't like
this guy bro of course not he annoys me
of course now
i don't like him do you think about what
you've got when you think about your
package
you are
you're a mate yeah
yeah
yeah it's true it's true
when you think about what you've got to
offer yeah
mate
you're a housewife's favorite no doubt
or at least a close second already i
recomprise the housewives yeah i
i am invisible for yes
vice versa
we don't have to worry about crossing
you know those dreams yeah i want to
know who's in the middle of it
with me and brian that's
that's the problem when everybody gets
it wrong
people boys always talk about threesomes
this is a good thing
if it's with two girls i imagine it's a
good thing but i don't really care but
if it's with two boys
very gay
don't you think of course genuine beef
beef if you're hanging out with this
we're talking about two there's nothing
wrong with two trees
nothing wrong with homesickness
nothing's wrong with that but that's not
your problem that's what you're saying
but what you're saying woman is gay
uh why is it here because there's two
penises there you're looking at another
erect penis
sometimes
the point is is that the penises are a
wreck because there's a naked woman in
between there's also
but mate it's cancellation isn't it
because if you've seen it if you said
double negative it's a double negative
exactly you're putting your batteries in
to end you're putting your batteries at
the wrong house if you see you've got to
put me up you see
a pretty woman walking down the street
and then you see and so you think okay
lively
i'm going to wake up i am then you see
an erect penis that isn't your own yeah
you can't use it
if i saw an erect penis that wasn't my
own in real life which i don't think
i've ever seen really you've never seen
another man's erection
i've never seen
how many other pieces have you seen
apart from your own
but you've definitely not watched any
kind of you know
right oh in real life
put it this way if i was in the same
room as another erect penis
i'd run
maybe
but they're my rules if i'm in a room
and my penis is in there and my penis is
a wreck well your penis when they're
always with you but if i'm in a room and
my penis is in there my penis is erect i
don't care if linda lucardi is in that
room
how about lucy and there's another thing
that's coming oh this is my penis so so
that that's an interesting one though
because it's like if you have to
if you could only [__] the dream woman
but you had a double team i was your
mate no you you don't do it what
no in here i'm not seeing one
i'm not saying that i'm into that but
like i'm just suggesting like maybe it's
it's not as bad as you think but it's
not on the table right bro i think
everybody i think mate the dream woman
i'd say do what you want to do just
don't give me no attitude right you can
do it but what you can't do
is tell me it isn't gay
it isn't gay it's okay but we're not
having sex with each other that no but
you're nearly deaf
really on the spectrum of sex it's
closer than what i'm prepared to go
right and that's fine and that's what
you need to specialize it's not too
[__] sex is a spectrum but i think
we have to work by the way rory what one
thing what about it's literally not gay
though
no rory rory what i'm saying is right
you know what's not you know it by the
literal definition of not being gay
you've got a woman that you are why are
you scared of yourself your penises i'm
never ever seeing your penis erect
if we play football together i might
have to [__] be grudging yes
i might be grudging
their penis
see that's another geezer that i don't
like brown and another do you know the
case that it gets dressed in the gym
under the towel oh it freaks me no i
don't get dressed under the towel that
makes me curious i don't get it
that makes me cute sorry so
why are you walking around with your
penis out in the gym yeah because i'm a
hair dryer and then what i do when i'm
here driving every now and again if
there's a bird there and your mate's
inside there it's
weird
looking at lots of flaccid dicks but if
any of them are arranged
how would you know if it's a penises
without looking at it clip that because
you can look just clip that out
why would you like
why would you voluntarily look at it if
i'm in the gym and somebody has an erect
penis i'm [__] out of there if i look
in a gym
that's a problem
and there is another penis that isn't my
own elliot leave please that's weird
that's weird
it's very it's very odd i reckon and
then do you know some dudes
they don't think there's anything wrong
when the penis is penis what's the
plural of penis penis
it's latin
and now he's gay now now he's just full
full scale home but
which is cool which is cool
don't pretend because there's a woman
there it's not right but what you're
saying so what you're saying is touching
it has no reason to touch
well one ep so if what if bp
just be honest just three three one's
going in the [__] one's going in the
ass
no not all the mouth at that point
they're balls double dick can
potentially look like vps
didn't know what it was just saying
everybody went to
school is he didn't know what he was i
did he did the the weird thing with rory
he keeps bringing the director of
photography every week we do we do we'll
do chelsea man city would do liverpool
united next year
and so every week he's bringing up
threesomes lads on his phone that he saw
when he was a kid and he didn't want to
see [__] and all that he was bringing
it up everybody showed you what i mean
you know horse horse stuff oh wait are
we talking about the horse that was your
[__] that wasn't my shirt
the guy who's got [__] to death by the
horse
that freak oh god you ever heard about
this you've never heard that i've heard
of it why is it like a myth no no no no
no i feel like i'm terrified i don't
know it's like so there's an old viral
all the boys back in the day we used to
um swap weirdest their videos on our
phones
you had to do infrared your faces are
definitely infrared you have to use to
put your phone next to each other yeah
so like
there was this video of this horse
climbing on some fella
and it climbs on the guy
can i just ask him how is the guy
stood so he he's on a small stool uh
let's just say he um is he inviting it
he's in position
to allow it right and the guy the other
guy who sort of prepared the situation
did he prepare the horse the horse isn't
a rapist i think i don't think the horse
needed much uh encouragement
horses are massive as well was this in
stoke
no that was in america it's more like
it's been in bristol
what are you all about i'm sorry and um
you've got a horse lads in the middle
you've got webbed toes no gas no gas
toast no i'm not ever seen in birmingham
this guy's got two three big toes draw
me all my life
my life on my life yeah but that's right
this form basically was was a was a
breeding ground you know you know for
men
who like to do stuff with animals and it
became sort of a little um
interesting story because i mean that's
not the interesting bit
the fact that he basically had the
horse's dick so deep in him that they
when the horse was done
he basically flopped and uh onto the
floor and the horse but they're right
there
that there was some internal injuries so
they had to throw him in the car
his mate after getting rory wait so they
wanted this to happen
here comes yeah they changed it rory i
just need to fill
[Laughter]
there's one of a woman as well but back
in the day when when lads at my college
you should just say video was that we
were like what the hell bluetooth yeah
mental um
so there's an old story called mr hans
where the guy was nicknamed that who
um his me
me the other fella some friends would
sort of help the horse
cram the [__] huge doc dick into his
arse
um
because it's raping the horse isn't it
it is the horse don't want to do that
the horse wants a philly so the the
horse one said woman but obviously
with his [__] man so the man he's
like well
if it's going very tight um
so
the horse shoves the dick right in you
hear the guy crying almost then and then
the guy's obviously so wounded quite
literally that um his mate has to drive
him to the hospital so his mate drives
in the hospital but his mate doesn't
want to be involved in this whole thing
so
he must have gone home and uploaded the
video because it made it under here
but what he did listen i'm busy i've got
to go and upload this
he dropped the guy off
at the hospital but by that i mean like
he literally just like rolled his cot
sorry ass out of the car and drove up
imagine the worst thing is the horses
finish shagging and then the guy goes
we've got to go to the hospital he goes
when i hear things like this when i hear
things like this i don't understand how
people can be against
uh
capital punishment yeah yeah yeah so who
should
i reckon right if you you can get your
rocks off to anything i don't care i
think anybody getting their rocks off
what's the best thing see the thing
do you know what i think like genuinely
with regard regardless
i just know that i just think sex is
good as is
it for me as is get it yeah but some
people they gotta get their rocks off to
whatever i think it's cool
i think it's how on earth do you get
your rocks off to a horse i used to live
in this we used to live in this alleyway
yeah we had like three houses in there
and like you know and you're on a normal
road and you just go in this alleyway
you got three hours in there and in the
three houses we lived in number two
and uh this old lady briefly lived in
number one or three on either side of us
and uh
she she used to be a crazy cat lady
basically my uncle
and that
must have got a job to do some painting
you know everyone used to do a bit of
cash in hand job at someone's house he's
gone around to paint their yard and that
catcher in hand and um while they were
painting this house they found a vhs in
there
i'm really wondering and it was a video
of the woman
doing stuff to cats on that that's
terrible bro
with
don't put this in the thing man this is
a festive podcast yeah
all the [__] i've said don't do all the
stuff you've said don't do that man
[Music]
if i ever catch a glimpse of myself even
in the mirror i've got a very awkwardly
positioned mirror in my bedroom if i'm
having sex and i see myself having sex
i'm like we'll look away now gay
i don't want to see that why well who's
filming themselves
i don't want to look at myself
this is gay this is gay my own i'm
getting mine okay
i know that's right because
is my own face
don't you ever look at it some people
they stick a mirror receiver be honest
have you never thought to yourself
wow i've got a pretty dick yeah i know i
do actually
i know i genuinely do that's what
happens when you're circumcised
yeah never pretty dick it's like giving
it bangs i don't want to know that [__]
why why sorry why why'd they actually
how did you know that about rory but of
course i know you've got a podcast
together oh he actually doesn't know
me because i'm circumcised i don't know
about me because i'm circumcised but
holy problem anti-semites yeah how did
you know that i have a rory how would
you know that about rory how would you
pick would you guess that about how
would you guess that
i'd have had that chat man
man up be a fighter you're the one
talking about knobs on the [__] night
johnny do you need to say mate you can't
[__] night that's his autobiography
though yeah
yeah
round the table just like him
sorry yeah
15 years younger than you ever
i want to know
yeah you're enjoying the moment rory
what what's wrong with that my face is
not the enjoyment what's wrong with
enjoying your own
yeah because in the moment you want to
think you look amazing
in my head you look like is it just the
face that's the issue or is there
anything else that you don't want to see
in the mirror face because also the
other thing is mold can be quite funny
and you don't want to be like like
you're not going to be laughing look
you've never recorded anything or
anything like that ever no
nothing nothing no no rory have you ever
sent a dick pic
no
i don't know
have you ever sent a dick pic no i have
no one to send it to you
i'm pretty good
sometimes i'll just go in there i'll go
brian's waiting for me to do true news
but i don't care i'm just going to stand
the structure so you know when you think
jane i'm being completely frank here
right i know whoever frankie is chelsea
man
they're pretty they
they are what why they are what women no
they have debut
debut what were we all about your penis
penises
tell me seriously have you ever looked
at your own dick and gone
god this is [__] gorgeous no because
but you have thought about at some point
in your life yeah when i was younger i
think it's more like the thing with with
me is i have no problem in having sex
in the mirror or on video you know what
i mean do you want to see it back
yeah maybe especially if you critique
your own performances
it's like where footballers look back at
their performance stop it there
yeah you're the youngest and most single
of the group here yeah yeah right so in
that sense um i mean that
you're very much youngest of course so
the youngest and least fertile you don't
always
why am i at least fertile you're least
favorite fitter than you give him
he's not about fitness
courses rory is very very he's already
he's got no sex drive and he don't care
i don't think i don't think you you give
off a vibe what vibe
you got
you know do you know what people call
you yeah mr virus the jaffa that's
seedless the jaffa that's what they call
it
people don't know you don't know there's
a couple
it means
so i don't think you have it in you
getting close what do you mean i don't i
i think if you had it in you i've
definitely got it i don't think so i
don't think let's be honest cockroaches
can have kids
exactly so rory good i i doubt i mean
very good easily good job i don't think
he's got it okay but yeah seriously the
booby movie
man
what kind of woman if we're talking
about the ideal woman for boovie what
are we looking at here man what is the
she's a sweetie
you know what i've dated a lot of
eastern european looking girls
oh i've dated a lot of
europeans yeah in other words i've had
sex with lost beautiful women
seriously
basically as long as they don't speak
english
yeah
but honestly honest to god is all right
in europe no it's just it's just like
not a decision i may i've dated you know
a range of different girls but you do
look a bit eastern europe
app
because it's like it's like instagram
you know tinder's very swipe and you
know but but hinge is very uh you know
you build a profile
yeah exactly it's more of a
so you have a little voice
no that's good move over to your corner
that's the point roy come on you're
getting very close to me
worried about what there's no erection
with you
it's okay
no i'm not i'm not reading my dating
profile out to you i know you should
because i think you'd be insensitive
ultimately i'm a romantic guy and i'm
out there i'm trying to find love and
you're out there sagging me off saying
these things
you do mate i was on a date the other
night and a group of lads were walking
past me and the girl walked into a place
yeah and they literally like sit you
[__] me yeah and i was like do you know
what this is my i went who'd you support
they were arsenal said mate arsenal
[__] embarrassing and they were like
they didn't know what to say she must
have been so turned on yeah
it's like
[__] she went
she went oh my god i bet she said
emergency fake called it she's organized
right call me and then i can get out if
i'm not being funny
or embarrassing
yeah yeah yeah i'm not even trying to
say on my heart
rory i think you're being harsh i i
think i'm not crazy
the biggest thing about this thing that
we do in terms of being a boss
seriously i'll get it i was on a date
with a girl mate
as soon as i met her as soon as i met
her in the summer this massive west ham
fan comes up to me he's with his family
and everything take ass for a selfie and
all that you think it does it can happen
right it doesn't it gives you weird
confidence in front of a girl it's quite
a nice situation in that regard i mean
it's funny there is something there's
nothing
you're there you're like oh yeah i did
it
and then and then the geezer walked away
and was like buzzing too i've met harry
maguire
and someone comes and goes can i have a
picture please yeah of course mate don't
worry about it it's it's an ego boot
it's a weird
of course i know it's shallow i know
what i mean in that moment when you're
dating obviously you guys are all dating
but there's also an element of um it
makes you safe because also you're
you're a bit of a public face so it
means that you're not just some weird
off the street you're also someone that
people go ah i know that guy yeah i want
a picture with it unless you someone
from af tv and that's different
so
you know when you're on hinge how do you
match someone
you just like you know you like what you
like i missed all the dating apps yeah
me too man you know tinder was very much
swipe swipe swipe
you missed tinder
the dating apps we use was high five on
myspace
yeah yeah yeah
tinder was just a full screen other girl
and then um obviously you're a guy you
swipe right swipe right if you like the
girl swipe i know what tinder is yeah
fine hinge
was the instagram of datamaps where it
was more like you know what's your
favorite movie what's your favorite
pickup line and it's more of a kind of
place
girls yeah so like if i was on your
instagram it's like you know what's adam
about hinges about what's this guy about
so tinder's for the losers more yeah
exactly exactly that exactly that so but
do you write a little profile and stuff
yeah i just sort of say i'm not being
funny but can we can we hear the first
sentence of the profile i'm just trying
to can you just read your book read your
profile
okay yeah but but rory you have to stay
at least two or three
you said eastern european yeah are you a
a tits man or an ass man tits
okay
so
very good so one of the prompts is like
all right change my mind about and then
it gives you the problem so for
me feel like
let's be honest we should all play this
game let's be popular you know in the
next last few months what everyone's
talking about lgbt rights
so change my mind about squid game yeah
that's why what's your mind about it
that's the point then you ask the
question that's how the conversation
starts and all that johnny why did you
change your mind about pretend i'm a
really fittiest european but yeah why'd
you change your mind about squeaky lens
it's not good i'm trying to do the
change mind about woman yeah
game
[Music]
that kind of vibe it's a bit cringy but
that's just not can you read anything
like that
my profile is just my pictures so
there's one
from the showdown
from the show down so you know what's
the other thing like that that sort of
you know
yeah but it's not it's nice
what are the things that you get right
in there though what do you have to
write about the caption for that is 2k
or gay
so it's about six pictures and then it's
these little prompts and that's what's
the problems what's up one of them was
about squeaking you know what does it
say what do you say
so take us through it one by one yeah
the prom was changing my mind about and
my answer was squid game because i wanna
all right so let's say what we would say
yeah right yeah so change my mind about
ferrari threesomes um changed my mind
about um
i've got less terrible the war in the
middle east charity football matches uh
what you used to hate them
now you like them changed my mind
changed my mind changed my mind um my
simple pleasures all right masturbating
i've said wine okay
[Music]
[Applause]
i do love red wine
but you know
is chocolate pizza is it in a chocolate
pizza book it's like fried bread
it's like baked breads this guy's unreal
the story you told rory about the uh
bottle of water
no i as much as is that painful i also
love it because i felt that same way
before it's terrible um and the terror
of being skinned and worried about the
pressures of life and all of that he's
one feeder it's healthy to to have that
though it keeps you motivated forever
that but does it
infiltrate and almost ruin
you today yeah mine does because my it's
called poor traumatic stressors yeah
yeah yeah we've all got pediatrics
especially people
do you know i think that's why that's
why
you are
the youtuber who basically makes a video
every bastard day which i respect
um and i know it's that this is the
thing that people don't know about rory
which i want to say is the amount that
he loves his kid and the way he is about
his family
that is why he graphs every [__] day
and i love you for that
you've i mean you're drunk but but do
you know do you know what i found a
killer
that
that fear of what occurred then but i'll
give you do you know what i did the
other day with a dear friend of ours i
went back to
with do you remember glenn cowie worked
at football yeah yeah good cameraman
good gazer good gazer like dear friend
of mine me and him i've done a video to
go out
uh over the festive period of backing my
flats where i actually grew up which
i've never done before i've never ever
spoke about it really just
in the flats went round
went to where i played football when i
was a kid went to around the back where
i used to go show my nan's flat my
great-grandmother's flat is this there
where we did the kickoff
very near it very near there
but what i've done in this video is meet
a couple of my pals that i grew up with
so the geezer so i lived a mile in the
sky
and the gage who lived in a flat below
me a fellow called rondelle rondell
we had met him we had a chat
and then we met another pal who's done
quite well he's got a gym and that
but what it became was
like a grafting it's hard you know like
you know when you suddenly go
no wonder i've got these anxieties i'm
talking to one mate he's telling me
about the struggles that he has trying
to earn money trying to duck and dive
see his kid and you're like no wonder
that we're all so
motivated round the table because
it can be so hard it can go so wrong
and and that's what like yeah i do a
video every day partly because i love it
partly because i love talking about
football but also partly because
of those lads as well to take the
opportunity with both hands yeah because
they don't have that yeah and then
it's a bit like that good will hunting
bit where he goes to his mate you
[__] owe it to us to get the [__] out
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i like that yeah
and and you've got you've got to haven't
you when you when you can
especially especially when you've got a
kid
you've got to try like you've got to
keep it going and do whatever you can
but it does become it does become
like i find the pressures of of youtube
i find you don't get me wrong youtube
has been amazing to me but i do also
find the pressures of it like it's mad
it's mad in the sense that i've grown up
from all my irish family were immigrants
living on benefits and you know
trying to get by here and there and
everywhere graf does yes but also we
relied on to stay a lot of the time as
well
discrimination amongst that family and
then even like my dad's family like just
growing up my dad had me when he was 16
at a graft
straight away pretty much and like
whenever i've grown up before i'm just
have to get a job and just graft so when
you end up in places where you
feel like i'm not supposed to be here
but i'm supposed to be living another
normal
life all the people that grew up around
me
are dead
some of them are locked some of them are
just doing other bits and it makes sure
because youtube's a weird position where
it's not like hollywood where you have
everything so you still have a normal
life bro and it
i've had this conversation with brian as
well where i don't know sometimes how to
talk to my mates bro because i have
issues or i have problems that i would
love to talk to my mates about but then
you feel like they can't relate to you
anymore because and they feel like you
can't really you know whatever they
don't come to you and it's like but the
thing is about you is you've always had
that like uh
you're very humble and you're like a
down earth character and i always was
watching what was full-time devils back
in the day when it was owned by a big
company and all of that before you guys
took it over and thinking
why are they not building the channel
around this guy why is he not the act
like why are they not did you mean steve
harrison um no
no but i'm serious like and and and now
i know you i know it's probably because
you weren't also
pushing yourself forward going i'm the
star give me all the credit and be in
taking all of the power that you could
have taken at that time whereas that's
the kind of move i would have made but i
was maybe not there but then i see
myself in you bro i don't think i've
ever said this to you yet but i see
an insecurity in you yeah of course i
know i know you you know that you've got
that absolutely i sometimes i see like
because you've come from a place that's
different to london and you your friends
are
you know detached from this kind of mad
london lifestyle in that that i see a
lot of myself in you i'm not i'm just
waiting
we're different because
i
you were carrying a channel and i always
thought this guy is great yeah i thought
it was just
look like i started a day job you get me
like i was i remember
day job i was grafting like i was trying
to get a job i just come out of uni i
had a degree but i didn't like my degree
so i was doing hot [__] and then
working with my dad and when i met you
when i met you i remember it was like
2014 or so
i think i'm right here you're an estate
agent i remember meeting you and you
were an estate agent i was like these
kids that i got introduced to back in
the day we were playing ping pong i
literally remember where we were that's
who he's an estate agent but this is
what he does on the side do you know how
i got the job i didn't even have a job
hey i got so lucky do you know what my
job was at the time so i'm working in
fremantle
and at the time i was i was a researcher
in tv i was a i was called a researcher
and
i was sorry doing research
do you know what mate it's actually it's
actually a bit of a moment i do not
remember what i was doing remember the
song wrecking ball miley cyrus yeah i
mean i mean i'm working on britain's got
talent so we're in the building where
britain's got talent scott filming
and i have to write a biography simon
cowell about miley cyrus so all day long
i've got a fine [__] that miley cyrus
has done at the time
i didn't like that was before her recent
stuff which is wicked right but this is
back in the day
you you was watching and i've got to
watch her i've got to watch her pretty
no no no she's got good she's got good
like proper good collabs would do a
lipper and that but
this is back in the day we're all
thinking and i'm and i'm having to watch
things that she's done previously so
i've got to watch her on norton to make
sure that we don't like repurpose the
same content or whatever i'm looking at
miley cyrus at the time i'm like going
mad
writing it all down for simon cowell i'm
writing a biograph 16-page bio he's
never going to read through we're never
going to read it never going to read
and i'm going this is just hateful when
i'm not this guy and i hate and all the
time i can hear this conversation going
on over there with a friend of ours
saunders i can hear it
and i'm going
what's going on over there they're
chatting about man united and they're
chatting about chelsea
and i was called a researcher right i've
gone over there can we then and i was a
bit like that when i was younger a
little bit like we are two minutes you
that's like that now
am i here exactly right but anyway then
i was double like it right like we did
he'd gone over doing this football thing
i was like okay what what and then when
we need a chelsea season ticket holder
wow
i went what i went a chelsea season
ticket holder
who's in tv there's 40 thousand max
and i'm in the room so [__] it's me
what do you need they when we need a
producer i'm a researcher i went all
right i'll try it that's me that's me
that is me
what'd you do here i said i work over
there with simon i'm on i'm on i'm doing
i'm not i'm not an employee of psycho
but i'm working for psycho i'm with
fremantle and i'm doing this simon
cowell but i need psycho productions but
and
this is it the geezer on the spot
basically when okay so i went from a
researcher skip two levels became a
producer
of the chelsea thing see
just going to me can you edit it and i'm
going yeah
in tv it's very different because in tv
does it edit sweet beautiful beautiful
life if you're at a tv you you exist in
a place called the village in just off
uh water street yeah
everything
everything's running my wife's at a
producer right so she sits in there with
the editor and she does the only wears
essex lovely life lovely my wife comes
home tells me she had that work nah
that's lovely you know lovely job
they went can you read it i went yeah of
course then what can you do what can you
can you do i'll take you oh yes
got a job somehow
yeah on the technicality but basically
there's 40 000 people in stanford
british 40 000 people
they weren't we need a season ticket
holder so i'm one of 40 000. then it's
how many people are available how many
people can do the job how many people
are in this room now how many people can
edit and rory that's always my position
i'm not even qualified but i'm gonna
tell you i am yeah and that's what i was
talking about earlier like people see
that we're now on the kickoff or we're
doing paddock or rory's got his own
channel or whatever and i think that's
easy bro yo we've been grafting for
eight nine years you know we should be
getting testimonials soon
it is mad are you now do you do you get
that you know how you've touched on sort
of mental mental health things and
whatever
do you ever now go
i remember saying this to you at the
anateria event
and you were on the floor actually you
were out spa
so he was just speaking
you're just lying on the floor and i
came over to you and i meant it and i do
mean it now
i said to you you've done it
and i don't even know what it is i don't
even know what i'm quantifying by it
but whatever the it you've done it you
know the saying and you're still doing
it look at that
i appreciate that i feel like do you do
you agree because you needed them you
need one of your mayors who you know
isn't a [__] i had to tell you stuff
in that moment and i'm laying there like
alan shearer is just looking at your
eyes going
thank you
we don't we don't do that you know and i
i fight
i find this people say it to me like we
don't celebrate the achievements we have
i don't know because me i feel like i
don't deserve them i don't know how you
guys feel but it's like about your you
deserve my own yeah we my achievements
so you agree in it and it's like you're
right it's like i feel like i don't
deserve them so you don't celebrate them
nothing that i've achieved over the last
eight years have i ever really
celebrated
and i feel like you you you might be the
same i am yeah like everyone might be
the same it's like i think when you're
in this you just feel this thing counts
you know what go ahead
if rory keen handy if you handed if you
personally handed roy keane
a check
i think that even you in your most
strict
belligerent sense of who you are and how
you don't appreciate what you've
achieved if you
had a moment with roy keane where you
were like but bro i've had i'm not i'm
not trying to take
i'm not trying to take anything off that
because that moment that and i even said
it to you bro brother look at that page
just just just appreciate what you've
done right now like
and and when brian mentioned his mom i
nearly went nice but it's like i played
at old trafford i've i've done certain
things where i should feel like bro i'm
here now i went to i went to south
africa with ryan giggsborough can i just
freeze
so what i think might be happening
though is because like you know when
like an actor for example does a movie
they have this whole time they build
this whole thing they let the viewing
public say it they enjoy it and then
they have the time off and then they go
back it's like almost like a fighter
we don't uh youtubers it's it's it's
week after week after week it's what's
next what's next that's the industry
that's what i said
and the comments
so
um
human nature is to only speak up if
something negative is happening because
if you're happy you're content you're
not really needing the talk so the
comments are usually more negative than
good and you're constantly chasing the
next thing so i think everyone here is
sort of trained to be that way but yeah
i mean that moment was was one of the
best
right in terms of who you are
there must have been a moment in that
mode in that
you you know the check because also you
can't ignore it it's very ceremonious
it's very it's very apparent it's it's
there it's it's visible and it happened
you see what adam's saying about maybe
the giggs thing it was like part of i
don't know i interviewed michael ballot
once i never thought about it again
until now like it just happened it was
part of life
what you did was you handed a hundred
thousand pounds to alishira and there
was a moment where alan shearer looked
like he might cry off the back of this
that's important but that must have been
a moment for you when you would like
okay this isn't
adam with gigs or rory with balako this
is
this is this elsewhere that's why it's
important yeah when we know that we can
we can be in these circumstances and not
really feel like we deserve it that's
why it's important that we go up to
brian go bro
though because is when i'm lying on the
floor
in disbelief and it really that whole
day felt like a dream to me even i can't
really remember certain bits you know
and i've got a really good memory but
there's certain moments where you know
when i'm i scored the goal and you got
mobbed me and and i run off i really
have very little recollection of that so
there's two goals so i'll tell you what
happened
the first goal shira weren't even there
though
um i can't remember all i know is i was
on the sidelines and i thought
price scored probably
we're celebrating right so we celebrate
and then after that sure was there
that's when you celebrate yeah so the
first one when you thought we stopped
you from celebrating with shira shira
wasn't even there no no i i get that but
like the whole day was a play and um and
all i remember thinking about was my mom
and stuff like that and thinking
you know because
there's been times
where i've been ashamed to be who i am
especially a couple of years ago i was
really in the throes of [__]
depression and i remember thinking god i
don't even want to go outside right now
like i don't even want to show my face
all of that and um everything i felt
like i'd worked for we'd had sponsors
pull out we'd lost so much money like we
i had like a lot of contracts signed for
things that i now all of a sudden didn't
know if i could pay for so to come back
from that and to then do something like
super positive for people who
it's not benefiting me it's not about me
and all of that it was such a lovely
moment and it was just this like but the
thing is you say that it's not about you
yeah and it's almost like i'm talking to
myself here because i need this kind of
talk something but it is about you
i'm a part of literally i'm a part of it
literally what i meant was it because of
you but it was you know
there's a you ever say old pictures of
yourself and think
i don't really like who i was then so
there's pictures of me
um
pictures that the laws have taken where
i remember the way i was thinking and i
and i'll and i think oh you were a
[__] ego maniac then like i really
don't like that version of me like the
one who was spending all the money the
one who was so
possession orientated like that guy why
were you like that though is it because
you know one of the things that i found
like is this
you know when when i was growing up i
never used to be or i never felt like
obviously i had everything my parents
they weren't together but they provided
everything for me but i felt like i
couldn't have what i wanted
and then as soon as you can it's like
[__] this
i'm gonna do what the [__] was it kind
of that thing it was it was uh
it was growing up where i grew up and
thinking i will never ever be able to
have those things in life and i've been
told by school teachers i've been told
because nothing prepares us for that
yeah
when i every way i work i was the scrub
kid you know what i mean so like to get
to that point where i'm driving a
[__] mclaren around newcastle
there was a moment where i couldn't help
but be a [__] because i remember
thinking it wasn't about
regular anyone p like regular people it
was about the people who told me i
wasn't [__]
you'll never have this so [__] you and
that attitude which in my head was
towards them just kind of dominated me
for a bit and became
who i was it was like my happiness was
based on what do i have what things do i
have what money can i spend on and
[__] material crap which is
and um
so that moment of of taking back the
cause to sell the cars which i told when
i rang lawrence when i was on the weight
of the bentley dealership like bro i've
got to sell this car up here
yeah i had this i had to sell my
bentleys pay the tax off and like i
literally got like
robbed like from the hundred grand i
think i spent on it to like
drive an underground car bro i've drive
more than that yeah and i was like what
the [__] um
and uh and i remember selling it back to
the the dealership going yeah i'm moving
to london so i won it anymore man no no
in reality i was like
i have no money at all
and uh and i've signed a two-year lease
on it on a i've spent hundreds of
thousand pounds on equipment and the the
company who promised me and we were in
negotiations with to sign a a deal
at the last minute because they'd hired
an imbecile pulled out and now the
content they're making is [__]
hilarious
um but anyway the point is the first
time i've ever heard rory said a c
bumble i i i i
i became
i became a person i don't like looking
back at i really dislike that i
understand i cringe i cringe at this can
i ask you in in five years time how how
will you look at yourself in this period
of your life with that with the alan
shearer thing not the alan shearer thing
was a day and it was a beautiful day
but also also you know even the channels
the final content that we've been
involved with how you've been so
independent how you've got you know the
likes of free trade involved and beats
people like that right how will you look
back in five years onto this period of
your life because you're talking about
you know a period of two three years ago
but you've done so well and obviously
i'm speaking from a position where
you've helped me as well massively and
you've helped rory and adam ever all of
us but how were you looking five years
at this period
i mean how did you view yourself so that
moment when i was lying on the floor and
rory comes up to me i can't remember and
but almost like do you know when you see
a movie and the guy's on the operating
table and he opens his eyes up and
there's then bright lights and
the the the doctor goes to the guy it's
me it's
wake up now it's all over it was a
little bit like i'm i can't eat i know
this sounds weird but it was really like
that and i heard rory go you've done it
you've done it and
in my head i was thinking
i've sort of conquered that demon of
like the selfish prick that i became and
now i'm like i don't care about what car
i drive i don't care about how much
money i've got i care about being happy
being around loyal people and now i care
about what really matters in life which
is helping people with what i've got you
know what i mean and it was i'm not a
saint but i'm a much better bloke and
that was that moment where i was like
yeah i just remember feeling like for
the three days afterwards i was like
really
to be completely frank
i had no idea that your mum had died all
right okay
my mum said it to me and i went i don't
think so
and then at the event
you obviously flagged it that that
that was a thing
and there was a moment during that and
i'm bad for this and i spoke to lawrence
about this already
but it was a moment during that
when you were speaking and we were in
biliricky
and lawrence looked at me and you know
when you make eye contact during a
moment
it can be powerful can't it and me and
lawrence mckenna made eye contact and
that was the moment when i was like
powerful i knew when i nearly went did
you know until brentwood no i knew
before that you knew that i bro if you
don't know yeah
and i don't know if brian owes this i
tell him a lot but he probably just
brushes it off if you're speaking i'm a
big fan of
like i'm a fan of bryce even without you
know the thing the thing about that day
was in my head but at the end of it the
thing i kept thinking about was like
careful it's just about knowing
when when someone's passed away you
can't have those conversations you can't
even though don't get me wrong i feel
like i've got a direct line to her
emotionally like i'm connected you know
what i mean so
i don't have to have those conversations
but i want you like everyone we all do
we all miss people when they passed away
but when i was laying there on the floor
i was like
i know i made you proud
you know what i mean it's not even a
doubt yeah and then to have that to have
that be like
i know
but bro you know you know as well you
know what i mean you don't even need to
do nothing extra to to do that
do you know what you need to you know
what you should probably know you know
the pressure you put on us by the way i
didn't without even realizing i didn't
realize until
i think i've played a final
in terms of that spirit
since i was i took on a different kind
of pressure where it was like right
now he's your manager representatives
you know what you said to me funnily
enough i think i mentioned this on a
video of my own
do you know what you said to me and it
was like actually very refreshing and i
think you probably need to hear this ad
from what you've been saying today we
were warming up
for the final and we were taking it very
seriously
and now we were
and do you know what he said rather than
go in
uh i'm
how am i here do you know do you
remember who went to me i'm really proud
of myself
and i kind of went
that's a good attitude that's a really
good actually yeah like because he went
i like i kind of went oh my god alex
here is about to watch to play football
my mind my intimation was amateur is
about to watch us play football are they
asked a lot what shouldn't be uh
should we stop it should we get bazinga
on here or whatever
and boovie went i'm really proud of
myself
but you said when i you see the opposite
to that and what we have
and
i think you have that as well so this is
a criticism of you but i think that is
what keeps you here oh yeah this table
yeah yeah like
because if the minute you start thinking
[__] i belong at this table is the
minute everyone just starts
ultimately i can ban to newcastle all
day long i know football so well and i
think this is the truth well you don't
know
who's going what do you know about that
yeah
on my life i don't know about football
we all follow football to a level where
whatever you know we know the stats all
this when you say it listen listen
listen
i don't i don't know newcastle i don't
follow you obviously i'm not a newcastle
fan but i can tell you i could write a
10 000 word essay of how what alan
shearer means to geordies to newcastle
fans to even blackburn fans on some
level because they're prominent football
fans generally so they love him they
really really don't know
but there are football there are people
out there that follow through
especially
their football fans out there football
superficially they don't take the
passion into it they don't take the
depth into it that we do the people in
the industry do and that's why i said it
because ultimately there are football
fans that would die that would sell
their kidney to to even be in the same
room as alan shearer yeah it's true
but you know he couldn't have a picture
until he until i was like you have to
have a picture you know you couldn't
even approach alan he's a gentleman
i really really like oh comes the real
one general i like cameron
yes he is but he went to me
i can't believe that she's here i kind
of like he couldn't go in for a picture
oh it cam
like you can't not yeah i i think i said
that you've got a like might have been
him or booboo when you guys let me make
you have a picture
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not even no i'm not even joking like
do you know what she did for me my girl
and this is this is the day that i was
like okay when i when i make some money
i'm proposing to you when i make more
money we're getting married
it didn't happen because i did pay for
the wedding but i've made money
because
do you know when i was
i was
at my lowest ebb bad
i got knit
in a terrible way in front of my mum in
front of my grandmother and in front of
my my girlfriend at the time
i got really bad nicking
and i thought
oh my like this is so bad and it was
kind of one way out of it
and it went it make we were at tottenham
magistrates you know it was one of them
where you just like
what's what's like the best case
scenario here is not guilty the worst
case scenario is like six can ask what
four sorry we're not going to go on the
d we're not going to go into details but
yeah consensus of what happened
and my
girlfriend at the time
who had no real loyalty like no real
loyalty to me at the time like she was
my girlfriend my mum was there my name
was there my mum
went mental and i had to pretend to her
that nothing happened
so she couldn't give evidence because
she would have died
my nan did give evidence because she's
of g
and my girlfriend at the time how long
have you been without this point for six
months nothing no no loyalty no loyalty
needed
no loyalty needed like she didn't need
to do it she didn't need to
completely tell her the truth is the
horse i rode in on and i'm gonna stick
with it she didn't need to
completely tell the truth under oath
she didn't need to completely do that
but but she told the truth
100 percent
but she 100 having known me for six
months you knew what was coming told the
truth she's like i back him she backed
me under and at that moment i'm not even
joking i'm not even joking like
who's a cab driver drove me to tottenham
driver take me to jail no no he's joking
it's another problem brian do you know
how [__] look look you see when you
say that with jest
the worst case scenario was six months
and you know what you do when you might
do that when you go that day you do take
a
bag with a toothbrush in it and then
like so that morning you go to your
misses
no no it's not a joke no it's yours no i
know it's not a joke it's just the
vision of you on the way with your
little bag
if you walk in prison mate i'm not being
funny
i'm still nervous
i'd worry about it
not because you're not
right
what's going through your [__] head
when you're in that car toothbrush bag
in terms of like fear
it was like the worst day ever that i've
had but it was also like the best
because i got not guilty
and
my
girlfriend at the time who i'd just been
with that day i decided like
i adore this girl i do that anyway
but you know when you demonstrate that
level of loyalty
like i've got friends that i don't think
would do that i've got friends that i
don't think i spoke to some of them at
the port i know they were slugging you
off so i agree
can i just say i don't do new year's
resolutions but let me just pour a drink
before i say this yeah the other thing
um i need to say
thank you
to you
mr brian
and to you mr lars and to the team at
the back and to everyone responsible for
the kickoff
as well
and at the front maybe sometimes there
was a time about two years ago when i
was ready to knock this all on the head
really when i've lost the job
everyone knows what happened i don't
need to go into that again and i
remember thinking what is the point in
all this every bit of progression that i
make seems to be just not
backwards and
partly buying paddock and becoming owner
and partly you guys giving me an
opportunity here
with the kickoff
and pog stars and showdown and all that
different stuff
has given me a new lease of life bro and
i don't think you guys kind of realize
what you did for me but
thank you you know what adam i
appreciate you do you know what
you know what i'm ready for i'm ready to
[__] it you know i can amplify with
regard to adam's point without even
talking about my own do you know what
adam said to me once
i was hovering around
90 odd subscribers
and you know adam pulled me aside once
as my friend pulled me out on a balcony
there and he went right they're talking
about the hundred thousand subscribers
you know that's a that's a
landmark in youtube
adam went listen mate
you'll never like
you may never make that
you may never make that hundred thousand
because it's huge it's just [__] it's
outrageous
truth is told
but also you may never make it for loads
of reasons because it ain't all about
meritocracy it ain't all about anything
you may never make it
so don't [__] worry about it but you
may never make it
and i went yeah yeah yeah i kind of know
that as well because i remember when i
worked at a company we tried for three
and a half years we never made it so
don't worry i know that adam
and within i reckon
we're in
half a dozen weeks of that conversation
on that balcony there
we both here
and that's only thanks to you and you
um
no i think i and again what do i know i
will appreciate it a lot of people don't
because the true geordi's on the name
people don't
yeah yeah that's just what i'm saying
but don't steal my thunder but yeah it's
like both both of them are yeah see when
i say both yeah let's let's uh let's
i'll tell you what right rory trying to
get a pay rise before me for [__]
that's one awkward conversation we're
all having it
uh i love you guys and uh i really
appreciate you being involved with
everything that we do
merry christmas everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
big love to everyone who watched uh we
love you guys and we really appreciate
it thanks to everyone who supports
everything we do thanks to jim sharp for
sponsoring the podcast
and we will see you with this lot on the
next episode of the kickoff as always
look after yourselves and the people you
love
merry christmas
[Applause]
is that what it should be because that
was [__] mental it felt like you
didn't do anything is that what you want
that's what i wanted